it's seven o'clock I'm Jonathan Samuels
and welcome to a Sky News special
program last night we reported a senior
U.S military figures warning that the
British army is no longer regarded as a
top level fighting force well today the
Prime Minister defended his record on
defense spending even as the armed
forces Minister admitted there had been
under investment for decades well
tonight with the help of an expert panel
of guests we're asking a fundamental
question about our role in the world at
a time of war in Europe and with the
prospect of new conflicts coming over
the horizon is the army fighting fit
Britain has long prided itself in
Fielding a force that others seek to
follow
Now sources have revealed a senior U.S
general told the defense secretary that
the British army is no longer regarded
as a top level or tier one fighting
force I don't accept that question at
all I mean we have the largest defense
spending any country in Europe
[Music]
puted when he looked again into Ukraine
he looked at political will must have
thought I'll factor that into my gamble
they're not they're not ready to
contribute anything other than good
words for a number of years to come
we have all made strategic errors in our
defense policies over the last two
decades because we've had treasuries
that have done short term we have
hollowed out as company governments
after government have wanted more but
not wanted to fund it his government was
no different I was serving in the Army
under his government I know exactly what
it was like
standing up to aggression everywhere is
good for all of our security and when I
was Chancellor we increased funding in
the armed forces by a record amount as
well because we wanted we recognize that
the world had changed and was becoming a
less safe place
the Army's programs are many billions
behind schedule and many years behind
schedule
I don't know whether he sees himself as
a wartime prime minister but he is the
prime minister is the prime minister at
the present moment and he's got to rise
to the occasion
we are now at war in Europe we need to
move to a war footing we need to face
Russia directly and reckon rather than
leaving Ukraine to do all the work
so let's bring in our guests joining me
from Kiev is our security and defense
editor Deborah Haynes who broke this
story last night General Sir Richard
Sheriff a former NATO Deputy Supreme
Commander for Europe Louise Jones head
of intelligence at McKenzie intelligence
Services who formerly served as an
officer in the British Army intelligence
Corps and Elizabeth brawl senior fellow
at the American Enterprise Institute a
very good evening to all of you thank
you for your time lots to discuss and
we'll get into the specifics soon but
first of all I wanted to get your
individual reaction to this damning
verdict from a U.S general and Deborah
perhaps we can come to you first what
sort of reaction have you had both at
home and abroad to your report
it's really underlining or confirming
what many people who follow defense
suspected or knew already the Army has
been underfunded for decades as both
conservative labor and Coalition
governments took what was described as a
peace dividend following the end of the
Cold War shifting resource into other
areas and the Army the Navy and the Air
Force all withering but the problem is
there has been new investment over the
last few years but the Army seems to be
the one fairing the least and right now
with a war here in Ukraine it's the Army
that's giving equipment to the
ukrainians and it really does expose
just how bare the stockpiles are back at
home
Elizabeth brore are the thoughts of this
U.S general more widely felt do you
think amongst the US Military
well the US military has one job which
is to to fight Wars and so of course if
in other countries armed forces are not
as good as the U.S armed forces they
will highlight that but we should
remember that that decision makers in
the UK have so many other considerations
to take into account so so I think it's
a little bit unfair on the British army
or indeed the British military as such
to to
um dismiss it as no longer first here
and and we should also remember that
this is not just the UK that's in that
position almost every European country
by Finland and Estonia have been or were
reducing their defense budgets for many
years until then in 2014 they started
spending more again so let's not be
overly unfair on the UK but it is
certainly true that that the British
army has has lost as Deborah said has
lost Lisa the sister Services has lost
more Investments than than maybe should
have been the case Okay in General Sir
Richard Sheriff you have a huge amount
of experience of the the British
military do you believe that the the
British army is no longer a top level
fighting force
well let's just be clear firstly the
people who serve the men and women who
serve in the British army are absolutely
second to none and the quality and the
commitment
um is is is is is is absolutely what
this nation needs but uh the US general
who said these words is absolutely right
um and I think that the truth is that uh
to be fighting fit and army needs more
than really good people it's got to have
equipment uh enough of it and it's got
to be modern and suited to the needs of
21st century Warfare it's got to have
Logistics ammunition and the capability
to really dig deep to fight the sort of
wars that we're seeing now in Ukraine a
a state on state industrial war and it's
got to have the sustainability
um the logistics of sustainability and
it's got to be able to train and in all
those areas Less in terms of quality of
people it is failing okay and uh Luis
Jones is here with me in the studio
Louise do you think we're still a tier
one military force or if we've been
relegated to tier two perhaps well
unfortunately you know and taking into
account the caliber of those who serve
unfortunately when you look at our
kitten equipment I think we're
flattering ourselves to call ourselves
even tier two when you look at the
investment that many of our comparative
countries that have made recently I mean
you look over the last decade we've
spent a similar amount of France on new
vehicles they've brought hundreds into
service and we've barely got a new quad
bike in okay well we'll dig into all of
this uh in a bit more detail shortly but
we have been speaking to the defense
secretary Ben Wallace this evening about
Deborah's story why don't we take a
listen to what he had to say
we were told by defense sources that a
senior U.S general said to you that the
British army is no longer regarded as a
tier one force how do you respond to
that well look first of all I've been
very clear for a number of years now as
defense secretary that the British army
has fallen behind its peer group and
needed investment and that's why Boris
Johnson in 2020 gave us a record
settlement supported by Rishi when he
was Chancellor of 16 billion pounds
extra in order to invest in our army and
we're starting to do that right now and
as I give you this interview there are
people making armored vehicles in
Telford and tanks and all sorts of
things which are the result of that
investment now clearly there are people
inside the building and across defense
that are very worried about the current
hollowing out of the army yes you have a
plan for modernization but they say it
will not deliver fast enough because the
threat is now and you need more money
faster what are you going to do about it
well firstly it's not the currently
hollowing out eventually a holiday under
labor and conservative something like 20
30 years I was serving the Armed Forces
when that hollowing was going out it was
that long ago this is the point that you
know the music starts to stop the
direction of travel changes we've had a
very predominantly peaceful and stable
world for the last 20 years that is not
the case anymore Russia is you know
inflicting a war on Europe in Europe
against Ukraine the rise of China the
tensions in the Pacific radicalization
across Africa the world is becoming more
unstable and more insecure and I think
that's why you know the prime minister
at the time in 2020 and Rishi recognizes
a requirement to meet that new threat
but it's not a new thing hollowing out
what we're seeing now is the
consequences of following agent you know
as a defense secretary I've always said
I'm not going to pretend things are
perfect I'm not going to sort of say
look over here look at the red arrows
and shoot for the color I'm going to
actually say that's what's going on
behind the scenes and we're going to try
and fix it and I would rather have a
perfectly formed properly protected men
and women of the Armed Forces offer size
we can afford and an ambition we can
afford then Pretend We're somehow you
know reaching Beyond ourselves
suggest said that the Army needs urgent
recapitalization that the PM gets it and
a budget is coming what does he mean by
that well it does need urgent
recapitalization and that's why we're
investing it we're investing 34 billion
pounds in the Army's equipment plan
between now and 2033 that's new
helicopters that is new tanks neon
personal carriers new electronic warfare
in a whole range of of Suite to
modernize the fleet something that
didn't happen in my day and I think it's
really really important that the public
understand we are doing it now the
criticism about it needs to happen now
is these things don't happen now there's
no magic one there's no factories
wearing away like like car factories
that you just press buttons and out they
come there are only about two countries
on the earth that can sustain almost
constant production lines out to China
and the United States and you know of
course we can seek to buy from abroad
but then there won't be a UK defense and
Aerospace industry and we won't be able
to necessarily give our troops the exact
equipment they want so we have to always
make that balance but you know Ukraine
is exposed Supply chains have been
frozen or you know out of out of out of
commission for far too long we face that
challenge Spain Germany France Italy all
the European countries face that
challenge and that's what that new money
is going towards and that's why it's
important to send a demand signal to
Industry to say we are investing that's
what we did with the Defense command
paper in 2020 we'll continue to do so
now finally what is the danger for UK
security if the PM does not give you the
increase in funding of 3 billion a year
that defense sources say is needed for
the Army well I I'm not going to go to
the these are defense sources first and
foremost we have a comprehensive
spending plan that takes us roughly to
the end of 224. we're on track to
continue that investment I think I think
the reality is as I've always said is we
need to modernize our armed forces and
keep Pace but there's also another thing
that we can do in government which is
make sure that we match our appetite
with the size of our stomach you know we
can do lots of things that British Armed
Forces our armed forces are some of the
best in the world but of course what we
mustn't do is over future over promise
and try and do everything for everybody
because that's in the end how you get in
financial problems so I think it's a
it's a two-way discussion how much do
you want to do that's how much it's
going to cost and then we come to an
arrangement but let's see what happens
in the next few weeks a month
so that was the defense secretary Ben
Wallace responding to Deborah's report
so why don't we ask the question then
what is the scale of the problem as was
suggested by that U.S general let's go
to General Sir Richard sure first you've
already explained what your worries are
but what is of of most concern to you
sir Richard is it a lack of ammunition
is it procurement issues is it the fact
that we now have a much smaller Army
I'm it's good to hear that uh the
defense secretary is getting behind the
wheel and determined to to make things
better but let's be clear as well it's
about the way the money is being spent
um yes of course we all understand that
times are hard and manage Insurance
Supply but I think defense needs to look
really carefully at itself and really
focus on what are the priorities where
is the debate about the nuclear
deterrent for example which gobbles up a
huge huge sums huge sums of money from
defense where is the debate about the
balance between the wolf nearest the
Sledge which is war in Europe uh and
deterring war in Europe and providing
support to the ukrainians and being
prepared for the worst case which is to
fight a land war in Europe on our
doorstep and the
shall I say Naval posturing we're seeing
in the in the in the indo-pacific region
which is probably a less urgent priority
nice to have
um where is the focus on the absolute
requirement for the kit that's required
it seems to me that we have an army that
is designing and bringing into service
equipment designed for the last war in
Afghanistan wheeled armored personnel
carriers a medium tank that has turned
into a procurement disaster in the Ajax
this is not a capability that is
required to Slug It Out with Russian
tanks in Eastern Europe uh of course
supported by uh Aviation drones and all
the rest of the plethora of military
kids so I think their defense defensive
industry needs to look very carefully at
its own priorities yes of course more is
needed in defense spending terms but
that money needs to be spent much better
okay let's ask Louise Jones uh a similar
question it does seem doesn't it that
the Navy and the RAF have had a great
deal of investment in recent years but
the Army really hasn't cut down to 10
000 troops why do you think the Army has
borne the brunt of of cuts well frankly
it's just a result of procurement
processes and decisions made not with
the Strategic long-term thinking that we
need but rather focusing on actually
where can we make the savings as soon as
possible at the Army's equipment
programs and most of its costs you can
make a cut to year in year so there's
been this really short-term thinking
that's meant that we've prioritized
spending on on the big ticket items for
the Navy and the RAF and also frankly
you know those higher up in the Navy and
RAF have done a much better job of
advocating for yes we need two aircraft
carriers those higher up in the Army
have not been effective in making a
similar case at all okay let's turn to
Deborah who's in Ukraine because many
people watching this Deborah will know
that we're sending tanks 14 of them to
help with the conflict out there but
there's the question if we're already
stretched what sort of hole will that
leave in our military back home so
well a big one I mean the fact is that
you had the head of the army a couple of
weeks ago in an internal message saying
that this giving of tanks and also these
as90 guns um big artillery pieces that
the Army is giving to the ukrainians
that that's going to make the Army
temporarily weaker to the fact that such
a relatively small sounding number of
pieces of equipment is having such a
massive effect on the Army back home
should really be an indicator of the
problems that you're seeing and I think
the fact that you're having government
ministers serving government ministers
openly talking about under investment
serial under investment those are the
words that James hepie used over decades
saying there's an urgent need for
capital for recapitalization again
underlining that sense of urgency really
should be alarming for people because it
does speak to a force that's nearly
broken some people I speak to say that
they believe the Army already is broken
and just underlining what general
Sheriff said it's nothing to do with the
Personnel serving there are great men
and women serving in our Armed Forces it
is about the equipment that they're that
they're using it's about the
hollowed-out stockpiles it's about the
fact there isn't money for them to be
training it's a fact that they don't
have the war fighting capability that
they're supposed to have if they are to
be this tier one fighting force that the
Prime Minister actually apparently still
believes that we have and is clearly
Something That We're attaining to return
to yeah so Richard that nodding his head
as you as you're speaking but it'd be
good to get the thoughts from across the
pond because Deborah
um Elizabeth uh sorry uh I wonder if if
there's a sense in the states that the
UK has taken its Eye Off the Ball a
little bit over uh recent years we've
concentrated a lot here on AI on drones
on cyber warfare more so than than boots
and bullets and of course now we're
seeing exactly that with the conflict in
Ukraine
well the reality is that the US Armed
Forces with
the 700
billion dollars uh and and even more can
can do a lot more than than the UK and I
think that the problem that the UK faces
that is that it's it never redefined but
it aren't its Armed Forces should be
about uh after the end of World War II
and then again after the Cold War so
we're used to the UK armed forces being
having Globe spanning capabilities and
and then when the UK declined as a
political entity in the world
uh nobody or there wasn't really a
conversation between the government and
the public about what what the role of
of the UK Armed Forces should be should
they still have this Global ambition or
should they uh be reduced to the size uh
of a country of um of the size of of the
UK as it is now uh today and has been
for the past 30 years so the eutan
forces as a result have been punching
above their weight for a very long time
uh underfunded and and uh and with uh
the men and women in uniform doing uh
great work uh but uh not with resources
matching the ambition that that was set
down for them and and that I think leads
to the question of should the should the
government have a conversation with the
public about what we want or what the UK
wants its Armed Forces to be able to do
with the public support a much bigger
budget and if so at the expense of what
but that needs to be that's an honest
debate that needs to be had rather than
the debates we had between among defense
experts who of course will all say that
that the Armed Forces need to be bigger
and have a bigger budget if the public
can voice its opinion and then uh if it
does voice it's a voice its opinion and
voice uh supports for larger Armed
Forces it would also be easier to get
that additional money to the Armed
Forces yeah you make a very good point
we're going to discuss that a little bit
later in the program what is the UK's
place in the world right now but you
mentioned budgets as well and I want to
concentrate a little bit on that and
look in more detail at what the data
tells us about how much the UK actually
spends on defense and how it Compares
with the rest of the world here's our
data and forensics correspondent Tom
Cheshire
this is really a story of choices behind
me is the UK's defense spending as a
percentage of GDP since the end of the
Cold War less money being spent as the
perceived threat recedes much of that
money being spent elsewhere this is what
health spending has done over a similar
period not too far off but really moving
away over recent years and that's a
choice made by successive governments
but that reduction in spending has meant
a reduction in Armed Forces personnel
and you can see just how much that has
fallen but the UK isn't alone here many
other countries reacted the same way to
the end of the Cold War this shows the
proportion of GDP spent by different
countries over the same time it's a
similar picture this is where the UK is
in Gold we're in the middle of the pack
really you're behind us and Russia but
we've spent much more than they we spend
more than they do in absolute terms then
you've got other countries like Poland
which today has announced it's
increasing its defense budget to four
percent of GDP the question is what do
we spend that that money on and this is
the equipment plan for the ministry of
Defense what are they going to spend
money on the next 10 years nuclear
deterrent is the biggest one then you've
got the rural Air Force the Army is
getting less of that money which is why
we've heard some of these calls and this
comes back to the integrated review this
idea of a global Britain a tilt to the
indo-pacific and for that sort of
strategy you need new equipment best
exemplify by the Queen Elizabeth class
carriers two of them delivered at a huge
cost 6.4 billion pounds to project power
across the seas some experts have said
that's putting money in the wrong place
they're expensive sitting ducks for
anti-ship missiles but land-based
systems often have a similar problem
compare those air carriers to the Ajax
armored vehicle the mod signed a
contract for 5.5 billion pounds for 589
Vehicles supposed to come into service
in 2017 but they have been plagued by
technical problems around noise and
vibration and we are still waiting on
that and Ajax is just one albeit a giant
program the Public Accounts committee
has said the ministry of defense's
entire procurement program is broken so
there is a lot of money more than nearly
every other country on the planet and a
lot of it is not being spent well
interesting stuff Tom Cheshire there
well let's look at the points raised uh
in that report in a bit more detail um
Louise the UK's NATO commitment then is
is pretty good isn't it you know we're
we're right up there
um why then do we have so much concern
that the the Army the military is
weakened so really the issue is not
necessarily how much funding that the
mod gets you know personally I wouldn't
give them an extra Penny it's how they
spend it we've seen so much wastage
we've seen references there to Ajax and
really there needs to be top to bottom
reform of the mod to make sure that
every penny of taxpayers money is spent
sensibly uh to for too long we've had
procurement done by enthusiastic
amateurs we need to make sure that we
get procurement experts in who can go to
these military equipment manufacturers
and get a good deal that will deliver a
piece of equipment that will be usable
by our Armed Forces you know until we've
sorted out all of those internal
processes of the mod you could you could
give them billions more and we still
wouldn't see an improvement in
capability it's simple as that oh really
interesting well let's put that exact
point to Sir Richard then it's not about
how much money there is it's about how
well it's spent would you agree with
that
I said earlier if you remember it is
about spending the money more
efficiently it's about prioritizing it's
about putting together a an inclusive
review of defense that looks at the
threats looks at Britain's place in the
world takes some hard decisions about
priorities as I said earlier do we do we
really you know we should be looking and
debating the question of the nuclear
deterrence you saw the huge proportion
of defense spending that goes on that we
should be debating uh the whole business
of the indo-pacific Tilt what worries me
is that I hear Vibes that say defenses
defense says that many in defense are
saying Russia is a busted flush uh we
should become we don't need to spend
money on on Central Europe and Eastern
Europe and and the land capability and
therefore the the global Britain
indo-pacific carrier strike tilt should
continue I think that is deeply flawed
thinking particularly with aircraft
carriers that frankly a white elephants
in in the sort of war that we are likely
to have to face in in Europe so I think
we have to to think very carefully about
priorities and we have to look very
carefully at how defenses spent how that
defense money is spent yeah let's ask
Deborah about that because we've heard
and we Millions
um on Warrior armored vehicles billions
overspent on those aircraft carriers
delays to nuclear submarines as well I
mean if more money was available
will the military actually use it and
spend it wisely
it's really really good criticism and I
think there's a huge concern looking at
the the track record on their ability to
spend money one of the things they've
been trying to do for the last 10 years
or so is to upgrade their Communications
gear so that they can embrace the fact
that all of us are able to send images
really quickly voice messages really
quickly and use that in their in their
armored vehicles and on their own
personal radios and just doing that has
dragged on and on and cost billions and
produced nothing so far so it's a really
fair criticism that has to get fixed but
the problem is now in terms of the state
of the army and that's why people are
saying they need extra money just to be
able to try to get these transformation
programs on track what general Sheriff
was saying about the nuclear program
that's a massive concern it takes up
about 20 percent of the entire budget
and so when that maybe overspends it's
eases out all the conventional equipment
which is again a huge problem and what
Elizabeth said earlier about
prioritization about what the government
wants its military forum and the defense
secretary said that too I remember back
in 2010 when David Cameron was prime
minister and they had this big defense
review they slashed the Armed Forces by
about 30 000 personnel and yet their
ambition for what they wanted the
country the country's military to
achieve barely changed at all the thing
that you have is that the UK it's a
nuclear power it's a permanent member of
the security Council it's a G7 Nation it
wants to have heft and Power in the
world and if it wants that though it
really has to pay for it and that's
where the problem lies yeah and and just
to conclude this section Elizabeth
um we've talked about the money but how
do we compare when it comes to Readiness
to fight that you know how do we compare
with other countries in terms of that
well I remember vividly um
primary conference a few
I won't mention which conference it was
but it was a conference where Army
chiefs were on a panel together and one
of the army Chiefs from a fellow
European country stood up and said well
I hear there's no time for jokes so I
won't tell you about the bundeslia and
that tells you something about the
bundesphere which is famously struggles
whether it's it's Readiness the UK is
much better set up or much that has much
better Readiness record than the
bundesphere but I I think also when it
comes if I can make him back to a point
that Louise made earlier about bringing
procurement experts there is so much
expertise um in the private sector uh
Executives CEOs chairman and Chad women
who have retired from very senior
positions in the private sector who
could lend a wise voice to the mod
beyond the the boards that that private
sector executives are already members on
and there was an interesting experiment
that the Swedish course is introduced a
few years ago where it hired a captain
of industry recently retired to provide
that sort of advice to the uh to the
chief of defense and he got to wear a
uniform I think it was a Navy Captain
uniform and it was a temporary
assignment so that he wouldn't uh he
wouldn't overstay his welcome but I
think that sort of expertise would be
really useful to bring in uh whether in
procurement or other areas where the
Armed Forces because they they have
their own expertise don't typically
Excel and which has resulted in these uh
these uh maybe not entirely successful
Investments yeah really interesting uh
thought that bringing in experts in in
various different fields to to help
um hold that thought for a moment
because we're going to talk a little bit
about the fact that defense spending
doesn't exist in a vacuum of course it
has to respond to the challenges of the
times and to the needs of politicians
and the public to ensure that Britain
retains prestige power on the world
stage well the last significant Mission
undertaken unilaterally by British
forces was to regain the Falkland
Islands back in 1982 Victory which many
doubt would be achievable with today's
military
the fall of the Berlin Wall in 1989
prompted the end of the Cold War and a
marked drop in defense spending across
the West as the Russian threat receded
the decade of relative stability that
ensued was shattered wasn't it by the 9
11 attacks in 2001 which triggered a new
age of insecurity and U.S and British
engagements in Afghanistan and Iraq but
without a significant increase in
military spending here in the UK but
despite the Middle East entanglements
it's been China which has in recent
years been seen as the dominant threat
to Western Security both in cyberspace
but also on the ground against Taiwan
now however it is a long Brewing
Resurgence of Russian military action
which has increased fears of
unpreparedness with the Ukraine Invasion
once again bringing War to Europe
well let's talk about the big picture
then and Britain's role in the world
we'll go back to Deborah I think in in
Kiev um do we actually need to be in
tier one Deborah I mean you've touched
on this already but do we actually need
to rethink our Global position
militarily and not get so hung up about
being the very best
well I think that is it's a it's a
political decision and it's a decision
as well as Elizabeth said that maybe the
public should be asked to have a vote on
um but I think the reality is that the
world as it is today with these
increasing threats from authoritarian
regimes
um challenging our way of you know the
way of life in Democratic societies
challenging that rules-based order that
has really grown up since the end of the
second world war designed to help
democracies and to try to restrict
authoritarian rule if we want to play a
part in protecting all of that then
maintaining a tier one uh top level
fighting force makes sense but as I said
before it requires choice of investment
it's not about asking the taxpayer to
pay more necessarily it's about maybe
diverting funds more towards defense and
absolutely crucially is about ensuring
that that money is spent better it
really frustrates me when you hear the
government
um bat off criticism about defense
spending and the state of Defense by
saying they have the biggest budget of
any European NATO any NATO country in
Europe it's nonsensical unless you look
at what that money is actually buying
and right now as we see with the Army
it's very little okay um General Sheriff
you're nodding away there um and I'm
playing the devil's Advocates a little
bit here
um but we'll always be part of a
coalition won't we why don't we
concentrate on the bits that we're
really good at and accept that perhaps
we're not going to be this Global Force
that's brilliant at everything because
we know we have allies to look after us
in those areas that we're not so strong
at
I think you need to consider two other
aspects which haven't been discussed
number one is the attitude of our
American Allies our number one Ally and
number two is the attitudes of our
European friends uh there would be
widespread dismay and I spent many years
in the NATO World widespread dismay and
there has been and I've listened to it
as people look look look at the way the
military in this country have been
consistently dismantled over the last
decade and they say to us what on Earth
is going on you are the one country we
admire and respect because we know that
we can rely on you for the quality of
your armed forces the second part I'd
make is or I'd add to that if we're
going to carry weight with the Americans
our number one Ally we've got to be able
to con deliver a credible capable
properly designed warfighting force it
does not have to match the Americans in
size of course not but one one one uh
one war you did not touch on was the
Gulf War in 1991 in 1991 where we sent a
properly joined up Armored Division with
significant Logistics all the artillery
that it needed and the air as well that
and that carried weight with the
Americans and if we are to carry weight
with our American Allies the absolute
minimum we should be capable of
delivering on the battlefield is a
division a properly joined up War
fighting division of twenty five
thousand together with the artillery
Logistics etc etc we have consist we are
now so far behind there we're going to
need a significant ingestion injection
of uh of funding prioritized perhaps
within defense but also from outside in
order to deliver that capability and one
final point is we started with talking
about the quality of our our of our men
and women in the armed forces we have to
look after them better if you go and
look at a lot of the army quarters and
other quarters and no doubt serving them
maybe in Air Force around the pizzas and
if you look at some other Twitter feeds
young families left without central
heating boilers breaking down because
the system for looking after our people
the money that goes into our into into
Maori quarters is Franklin divisary and
it's not surprising that people are
probably likely to walk because they're
not being properly looked after in that
respect okay
um lots to uh think about there with
Louise Jones in the studio
um what do you take away from what
general Sharif was saying there well
just to approach his last point is
absolutely right you know a department
that can't even run a contractor to fix
boilers in people's houses I don't see
how we could trust them to deliver
complicated equipment programs at the
same time and then also just for some of
the points that he raised earlier there
are some very difficult prioritization
calls that need to be made we really
need those in government to be very
brave about which sacred cows we're
discussing I'm not necessarily sure I
would agree with Sir Richard about
necessarily the nuclear deterrent but
there's plenty of uh sacred cows we
should be addressing for too long the
Army has tried to hold on to certain cat
badges certain Legacy capabilities
you're not having a parachute Brigade
there's really difficult decisions that
have got to be made and only then can we
raise the investment needed to as the
general alludes to really have a reset
and deliver a wall fighting division now
I wouldn't necessarily say that we
should stick to the old ambition of
being just as good as the Americans but
you know in one small package we really
need to look at how we work with our
allies to make sure that we complement
of course we need decent artillery very
important we have a logistics chain
which is completely missing at the
moment but fundamentally we need to make
sure that we are more closely
complementary with our allies than we
have been before okay thank you for that
and let's get a final thought shall we
from Elizabeth Elizabeth brawl in
Washington I mean do you think the UK is
kidding itself Elizabeth about the need
for a mighty Army do you think it's
become almost a status symbol for us and
that perhaps we need to to rethink the
the the size of it
well it certainly has become a status
symbol and and it's one of the things
that that makes the UK what what it is
uh that no other country has an army at
the at this level at its disposal for
for a tasks ranging from uh the Queen's
funeral to uh to providing uh oxygen in
all manner of of PPE during the during
the covet crisis to fighting complicated
um uh uh conflicts in in far away
countries it's it's really uh extremely
impressive but the fundamental problem I
think is that all these men and women
are hidden from public view except when
there is a crisis when they turn up and
and and delivered whatever it is that
needs to be delivered or and Carry Out
ceremonial duties or indeed fight Wars
and if we don't have that connection
between the Army and and the general
public the general public won't realize
that this is a a crucial institution
that needs to be funded and that it
consists of men and women like them and
if we had more interaction between uh
the Army and indeed in the Air Force and
and and the Royal Navy I think the
public would be much more interested
much more willing to support support
larger budgets and they would also
indeed be much more willing to join the
Army themselves but with these large
basis that we have hidden from public
view how are people supposed to feel uh
feel a connection to the Army and uh so
I wish though there would be more
interaction maybe through open houses in
in an army bases uh I I realized our
security issues but without that
connection it's not an army and and it's
not the military representing the wider
public and and as a result the why the
public will feel less connection to it
yeah something Americans do very well of
course well it's been a fascinating
debate you've all given us lots to two
over thank you very much indeed that's
all for this special program my thanks
to all of my guests Deborah Haynes in
Kiev General Sir Richard Sheriff former
NATO Commander also Louise Jones here in
the studio head of intelligence at
McKenzie intelligence services and
Elizabeth brawl speaking to us from
Washington Senior fellow at the American
Enterprise Institute good to see thank
you